well it has been a big week in the
identity theft hacking world on that the
first of the week Capital One revealed
that they are changing their slogan
after a hundred million files were
hacked a hundred million people that's
bizarre in a hacked by a Seattle hacker
who is trying to be an anarchist and
innocence today domestic cyber terrorist
and needs to go to jail for decades
hundreds of millions of dollars of cost
that this one crazy chick has cost the
public and this bank I'm not a fan of
Capital One we did get some inside
information that they are changing their
slogan from what's in your wallet to
what's in your wallet
oh wait everyone already knows oh and
Equifax comes out Equifax our big friend
at the credit bureau worst service of
any company or organization ever on the
planet unbelievable
with the possible exception of Capital
One and as you know they managed to lose
a hundred and forty seven million
consumers files in a hack in a an
identity theft process as well and the
thing about Equifax is this here's the
deal if you do business with Capital One
that's your fault you're dumb you chose
poorly and then they get hacked and they
weren't do anything wrong that they
didn't deserve to be hacked but I mean
you do business with somebody like that
then you just deal with that the thing
about Equifax is I don't do business
with Equifax you may not do business
with Equifax but they make money off of
collecting your data without your
permission no other organization on the
planet is allowed to do that other than
the credit bureau reporting agencies
there's three of them Equifax being the
largest they collect data on you without
your
mission and sell the data on you and
make money on it without you being
compensated or without your permission
there's a little something morally wrong
about that in a world where everyone
else is very restricted there's federal
laws in place Privacy Act that says you
can't share someone's payment
information with someone else and yet
we're all supposed to share everything
with Equifax because some goob decided
to so Equifax gets hacked 147 million
people you go through the whole process
with the Federal Trade Commission and
finally get slapped on the wrist and
they have a whole three hundred eighty
million dollars set aside which is
supposed to give you $125 back if you
spent $125 on credit repair credit
monitoring or your time and you can
prove that however if you do a little
quick math 147 million times one hundred
and twenty five dollars comes out to be
a whole lot more than 380 million
that's what three dollars a piece is
what's allocated in the restitution fund
and so if everybody goes and tries to
get their hundred twenty-five dollars
coach everybody done can't go get it
because everybody didn't spend it but if
you are if that you know mathematically
this is what's known as a joke a joke
it's ridiculous it's a scam and the
government's walking around strutting
like they did something you didn't do
anything you wuss
you completely let this bogus
organization off the hook 380 million
dollars on a hundred and forty seven
million people losing their information
that's $3 a piece you goups
some mathematical joke I propose that
Equifax sends me a thousand dollars a
year for the rest of my life for using
my information there's your new joke
haha I don't think this is gonna be
happening anytime soon
52% of the files and Equifax have errors
37% one-in-three have errors so severe
they will keep you from getting credit
not as if I want you to go get a bunch
of credit so do you need to rush down
and file for your hundred and
twenty-five dollars before everyone else
doesn't know cuz you're not gonna get it
they're not required to give more than
380 million so if it ends up that more
people apply then they can reduce the
amount from hundred twenty-five dollars
down to whatever it is however many of
you apply it could be ten dollars a
piece it could be eighty dollars a piece
oh and there's articles all over the
place already that you may run into
settlement website issues when you go to
their website here's a shock of shocks
it's hard to use it's incomplete it's
inaccurate and it doesn't work kind of
sounds like Equifax hard to use
incomplete and it's hard to work so your
credit score that some of you are so
freaking proud of is determined by an
organization using your data without
your permission and profiting from it
and 52% of the time there are errors on
it 37% of the time the errors are so
egregious as to which to keep you from
getting credit or damaging your precious
credit score and that's for those of you
that worship at the altar of the great
FICO so you can go try to get your
hundred twenty-five dollars back I
wouldn't bother it's gonna ring you're
gonna run into more trouble here's what
I would do what I did years ago as soon
as the law allowed I froze my credit
bureau report and I froze my wife's and
it froze all of my kids and they're
still all frozen why we don't borrow
money so there's no need for you to
check my credit if you need to check my
credit to do business with me we're not
going to be able to play together
because I just is I don't need Equifax
to establish my identity or for that
matter to get it stolen so when your
credit bureau report is frozen that
means they can no longer make money off
of you without your permission that part
I really like can you tell and in
addition that once it's frozen if
someone did steal your identity and if
they applied to a company to get a loan
that did bother to check credit before
making the loan which not all of them do
it would prevent some identity theft not
all so you should get out of the credit
business get out of the debt business
and get out of the Equifax business Wow
this sounds so clean simple pure like
back in the day before people used our
data without our permission to make a
profit and then lost it
147 million times and then managed to
settle with the government to pay
everybody $3 Wow scam upon scam upon
scam it's a scam sandwich there you go
folks
unbelievable Wow freeze your credit
bureau report call Xander get your
Xander insurance identity theft
immediately in place because between
Capital One what's in your wallet Oh
everyone already knows and Equifax with
their level of service you're pretty
much screwed out there people this is
the Dave Ramsey show